on continue de décortiquer cette
nouvelle forme plus radicale plus
violente du haut du mouvement contre la
réforme des retraites avec un autre
regard celui de trois correspondants
européens une portugaise en Suisse et un
anglais ils sont juste là dans les
coulisses d'abord comment notre période
politique cette crise politique est vue
de l'étranger Hugo le meunier commence
justement par l'annulation de la visite
du roi Charles III
le chaos en France à la une du Times la
Révolution française qui empêche la
visite de Charles pour le Daily Mirror
les manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites font les gros titres de la
presse britannique après l'annulation de
la visite royale à Paris et devant les
caméras des Chaînes d'information la
colère des opposants à Emmanuel Macron
les feux de poubelles sont devenus le
symbole de cette contestation dirigée
contre un président accusé d'outrepasser
la volonté du peuple
de même en Espagne ou la télévision
publique insiste sur la violence des
affrontements dans les rues de la
capitale cette manifestation a été la
plus violente il y avait cette fois
mille Black Blocs issus des groupes
d'extrême gauche
de l'Opéra où cela s'est terminé la
foule a été dispersée avec des
confrontations brutales et des tirs de
grenades lacrymogènes
vu de l'étranger les observateurs
dénoncent un emploi disproportionné de
la force par les autorités
des inquiétudes que relais le Conseil de
l'Europe les actes de violence
sporadiques de certains manifestants ou
d'autres actes répréhensibles commis par
d'autres personnes au cours d'une
manifestation ne saurait justifier
l'usage excessif de la force par les
agents de l'État la crise que traverse
la France est aussi instrumentalisée
comme ici par la propagande historique
olgase cabayeva star de la télévision
d'État 10 tonnes d'ordures ont déjà été
brûlées à Paris au pied de la Tour
Eiffel une odeur pestilentielle se
répand partout dans l'est de la capitale
à la Porte de Bagnolet regardez des
hordes de rats copulent dans les
décharges dévore les restes du bien-être
européen la France sous le regard du
monde à la veille de la dixième journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites
on devrait regarder beaucoup plus
souvent la télévision en russe
j'accueille Anna Navarro Pedro bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes correspondante de la
presse portugaise Richard Verdi bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
correspondre en France Europe pour les
médias Suisse Blic Philippe bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
britannique à France 24 et Mathieu
croissanto est resté à mes côtés
évidemment peut-être un avis général un
tour de table pour commencer la nanaro
Pedro comment on commence cette crise
politique française comment vous la
percevez et comment elle est perçue au
Portugal au départ on va dire qu'il y
avait un peu d'incompréhension du fait
que tout se focalise essentiellement sur
l'augmentation de l'âge de départ à la
retraite les 64 ans parce qu'on est dans
un pays où l'âge de départ à la retraite
approche des 67 ans
ensuite on a compris beaucoup d'autres
choses on a compris qu'effectivement il
y avait aussi une augmentation très
importante les annuités alors que chez
nous et dans des autres pays européens
elles sont beaucoup plus vastes donc on
peut partir bien avant l'âge légal avec
une pénalité en fait et c'est plus
souple dans notre pays malgré un cadre
plus on semblerait plus rigoureux plus
plus important et puis on a compris sur
tout l'absence totale de dialogue et et
l'absence totale de compromis vous savez
Laurent Berger le patron de la CFDT en
France et aussi de patron le président
de la Confédération européenne des
syndicats ce qui veut dire que il fait
un très bon travail d'explication auprès
des syndicats de toute l'Europe ce qui
se passe en France et ça c'est relayé
dans nos pays respectifs par nos
syndicats auprès des éditorialistes des
politiciens des économistes etc ce qui
fait qu'il y a une bonne formation en
règle générale sur ce qui se passe ici
donc maintenant
la situation est on a très mal perçu
l'utilisation de 49-3 parce que non pas
parce que c'est illégal non on a très
bien compris ce que ça veut dire en
France mais on aperçu qu'elle a été
utilisée parce que le gouvernement
risquait de ne pas voir adopté son
projet de dans le Parlement et donc ça
ça a été très mal perçu comme mesure
anti-démocratique de l'utilisation de
cet article constitutionnel et puis
maintenant le problème c'est que il y a
deux choses dont on parle beaucoup chez
nous c'est que d'un côté on va se dire
que toute la situation en France
extrêmement bloquée et vraiment
suspendue au risque de dérapage qui va
déterminer les rapports de l'autre ou de
l'autre et
puis le risque plus général de voir un
peuple tourné le dos à la démocratie qui
n'est pas le seul en Europe d'ailleurs
Richard Berly est-ce que finalement
cette crise politique elle s'inscrit
dans une longue tradition française ou
est-ce que elle est voilà c'est c'est un
moment particulier c'est un niveau
particulier ou supérieur de crise bon ça
ne vous étonnera pas vu de Suisse
francophone on connaît assez bien les
Français on connaît leurs caractères
volcanique leur aspiration à la
révolution donc je dirais le côté
fiévreux du pays ça il n'a pas étonné de
même que le blocage de la sous forme de
retraite on s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait
une mobilisation sociale forte mais il y
a deux choses qui étonnent vu de Suisse
encore une fois le premier c'est
pourquoi un tel refus d'emblée et même
encore aujourd'hui du référendum parce
qu'il y a plusieurs leaders de gauche en
Suisse qui ont dit que une réforme des
retraites pouvait très bien être soumise
à référendum d'ailleurs en Suisse elle a
été aujourd'hui la retraite a lieu à 65
ans l'âge légal et c'est suite à une
votation comme on dit chez nous qui a
lieu ce qui prouve qu'on peut très bien
expliquer une réforme des retraites pour
un référendum contrairement à ce que
j'entends dire mais dans un pays on a
l'habitude du référendum et des
votations
on peut s'y mettre on peut les acquérir
aussi et puis la deuxième
incompréhension c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement en l'occurrence pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas mis sur la table
de manière plus claire dès le début ce
qui vue de Suisse constitue la raison de
cette réforme c'est à dire les finances
publiques la peur de la dette la peur
des marchés financiers la peur des taux
d'intérêt des agences de notation
pourquoi au fond il n'y a pas eu un
donnant donnant au départ en disant nous
faisons cette réforme parce que les
finances publiques sont dans un état
catastrophique et on n'a pas le choix il
faut donner des signes et ça de vues de
Suisse on ne comprend pas parce que même
dans son allocution du de mercredi
dernier Emmanuel Macron a parlé de ça
mais il n'en a pas parlé de manière
claire et limpide en disant nous sommes
exposés à une hausse des taux d'intérêt
vu le volume de la dette française qui
je pense est de 3000 milliards d'euros
ça a été un arrivant parmi d'autres
parce qu'on a eu beaucoup des arguments
pour les parce que c'est un argument
qu'on peut lui retourner vous faites
cette réforme pour les marchés
financiers
c'est ma réforme et on peut aussi lui
dire que c'est le coup du quoi qu'il en
coûte qui se répercute aujourd'hui bien
sûr c'est presque un signal de fin du
quoi qu'il en coûte que il avait choisi
de donner quand il a décidé après
l'élection présidentielle législative de
de maintenir cette réforme malgré le
climat particulier Philippe la
prestabilité Britannique je sais pas
c'est toujours vrai mais on a ce
sentiment qu'elle s'en donne à cœur joie
pour critiquer la France depuis des
années comment le l'annulation de la
visite du du roi Charles III a été
finalement présenté perçu on s'est moqué
de nous vous savez si tu ouvres c'est
sur bonne guerre quand on a une occasion
en Grande-Bretagne il faut pour se
moquer des Français et ben allons-y on
le fait parce que ça peut mettre aussi
la Grande-Bretagne dans une position de
force depuis son sol vis-à-vis de la
France donc c'est rivalité qui dure
depuis des siècles et toujours vivant
aujourd'hui donc le fait que le roi
vienne pas je dirais que il y a ceux qui
ricanent en disant encore une grève en
France parce que à un moment il y avait
des mises en garde pas seulement
maintenant mais toujours dans le passé
attention si vous arrivez en France
parce que quelque part il y aura une
grève donc vous allez avoir des
problèmes
tout le temps partout et donc le roi
première visite d'état depuis qu'il est
roi depuis septembre dernier juste un
mois ou quelques jours avant le le
couronnement et maintenant ça se passe
pas parce qu'il y a grève en France et
donc il
[Musique]
c'est pas possible donc je pense que
alors évidemment le ça nous fait rire
sur le gâteau c'est pas nous qui avons
annulé c'est la France qui a annulé et
la France images c'est pas nous c'est la
Grande-Bretagne qui a décidé de ne pas
venir donc je pense que c'est un peu les
deux hein on dit bon pour la France ça
marchera pas l'image est désastre et
pour la France et pour Macron et puis
potentiellement pour la monarchie
britannique on va redevenir sérieux
parce qu'on va parler de la question de
des violences de l'usage légitime de la
force par les policiers et les et les
gendarmes il y a évidemment beaucoup de
de polémiques autour de cette thématique
et je vous propose un document de nos
confrères partenaires éditoriaux de
loopsiders ils ont réussi à obtenir un
échange entre des policiers de la brave
m vous savez c'est c'est
policiers qui sont à moto voilà je
cherche voilà c'est ils sont à moto ils
sont deux il y en a un un qui pilote il
y en a un autre derrière ça nous
rappelle malheureusement
1900 les Voltigeurs de maiko cycline
donc bon voilà et donc il y a une vague
d'arrestation et puis ensuite il y a
cette conversation elles entend qui
dérape ça se passe dans le 3e
arrondissement de Paris et c'était le 20
mars dernier
[Musique]
20 secondes ça dure pendant plus de 6
minutes donc et puis il y a des menaces
il y a des insultes un avion Pedro on
essaye de se poser la question tous
ensemble de l'image de la France et de
peut-être de l'impact à long terme de
des images dont on parlait ou d'une
séquence comme celle-là tiens pour
commencer est-ce que il y a une partie
de la jeunesse portugaise qui regarde
sur les médias sociaux les réseaux
sociaux des images de violence ou des
séquences comme celle-ci oui on regarde
parce que ce n'est pas habituel quand
même de voir des manifestations qui sont
en gros pacifiques être réprimer ces
violemment ça nous rappelle d'ailleurs
dans les périodes d'austérité au
Portugal on a eu une répression d'une
manifestation très pacifique devant le
Parlement très violemment préprimé aussi
par le gouvernement de l'époque et c'est
resté dans les donc oui et c'est pas que
la jeunesse portugaise je vois qu'à
Athènes à Madrid à Santiago du Chili
vous voyez des jeunes qui se maquillent
qui manifestent solidarité avec les
jeunes Français vous avez sur Youtube
beaucoup de jeunes journalistes français
qui sont dans les manifs le soir des des
jeunes j'utilise le mot très souvent
mais Tesla et qui les suivent et donc on
voit dans on continue sur trois quatre
cinq six heures ce qui se passe dans la
rue il y a jamais d'interruption il y a
pas de il y a pas de coupure c'est comme
si vous y étiez donc on voit il y a des
jeunes qui sont déjà venus en brésilien
maintenant qui fait cela pour le Brésil
pour le Portugal etc donc on voit
exactement direct les manifestations et
on voit on dirait exactement ce qui se
passe on voit que c'est jeune pour la
plupart ne cherche pas la bagarre avec
la police et par contre la répression
très violente faut dire aussi que les
policiers sont assez fatigués que ces
jeunes cavalent très vite en Paris qui
peut faire 10 km au moins d'une heure au
moins d'une heure et demie et que les
policiers sont et on le sait il y a
certains manifestants qui en fait se
glissent dans dans la manif ensuite
mille et 1500 lors de la dernière
journée de manifestation c'est quand
même plus compliqué pour les forces de
l'ordre de gérer cette situation parce
que justement c'est à l'étranger au
Portugal ne le fait pas et je pense que
à l'étranger on ne le voit pas très
souvent faire la malgame qu'on voit dans
en France être fait par rapport à ces
violences on parle des violences dans
les manifestations alors que la plupart
des manifestations ont été très calme
jusqu'à présent très pacifique
qui a les Black Blocs qui sont arrivés
pour la première fois dans tout ce
conflit social qui dure depuis deux mois
et que effectivement on a immédiatement
fait La Malga entre la violence et black
bloc et celle de la manifestation qui
était inexistante moi j'ai pas eu le
sentiment d'en discours politique c'est
amalgame a été fait mais la question que
je posais et puis je vais vous donner la
parole à bien entendre que tout le monde
puisse en dire un mot pour pour
commencer peut-être Richard Verly sur
c'est toujours très compliqué parce que
chacun se renvoie la violence de l'autre
quoi dans dans un dans un moment comme
celui-là oui alors ce qui est sûr c'est
que la police française vue de
l'étranger vu d'un pays comme la Suisse
par exemple où nous avons une tradition
Black Bloc notamment à Zurich en Suisse
allemande il faut le savoir mais la
police française est vue comme une
police violente une police qui frappe
j'allais pas dire qu'il frappe d'abord
et qui pose les questions ensuite mais
il y a ce sentiment d'une police qui va
au contact et il y a certaines images
d'ailleurs on voit même la police foncer
sur la foule et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne connaît pas c'est de notre
histoire aussi voilà exactement donc
cette violence policière elle est je
dirais
connue en ce qui concerne la France ce
qui est plus étonnant et ce qui étonne
maintenant c'est d'abord le retour de
ces brigades motorisées compte tenu de
ce que vous avez dit c'est à dire qu'il
y a 30 ans en 1986 au moment de je crois
des manifestations pour la réforme
contre la réforme des universités le
décès de ce garçon Malikou c'est qui
savait beaucoup frappé les esprits on
voit revenir ces brigades motorisées
donc c'est quelque chose qui surprend un
peu on avait pensé qu'elles étaient
qu'elles avaient disparu pour de bons on
les avait vu aussi au moment des gilets
jaunes certaines il y avait même des
images elle s'était fait coincée à un
moment donné des escouades de policier
c'était fait coincé donc recréer en 2019
voilà et l'autre chose qui étonne c'est
la tactique encore une fois je le disais
il y a quand même des images où on voit
littéralement les policiers foncés ou
vouloir couper la manifestation en deux
c'est quand même prendre des normes
risques de vouloir couper une
manifestation en deux et la question
qu'on se pose c'est pourquoi pourquoi ce
type de management policier et là on n'a
pas vraiment la réponse alors leur
justification c'est de dire il voit se
former des Black Blocs et donc à ce
moment-là il faut intervenir je ne fais
que reprendre la justification qui a été
donnée par par la préfecture de police
de Paris comment la police britannique
agit-elle face à ce type de de violence
est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a une
stratégie différente est-ce qu'il y a
que la police politique n'est pas armée
comme quoi
il est vrai que je rejoins ce que dit
Richard qu'à la police française aurait
une réputation de d'être violent et
d'être très dur et d'ailleurs on m'a
souvent fait la réflexion Grand-Bretagne
faites attention en France comme vous
êtes face à la police parce que c'est
pas du tout la même chose qu'en
Grande-Bretagne et ça rigole pas donc si
vous avez envie de aller dans une
manifestation ben vous allez être
extrêmement bien entourée par la police
donc il faut pas faire de bêtises est-ce
que on fait le lien dans les médias ou
peut-être dans l'opinion avec ce qui
s'était passé à la finale de la de la
Ligue des Champions entre Liverpool et
le Real Madrid où il y avait eu un
gigantesque bug d'organisation ouais je
pense qu'il y a il y a quand même une
comparaison à faire dans ces deux cas
c'est-à-dire que pour moi autrefois
quand on monte dans le temps il y avait
des manifestations et des syndicats qui
étaient presque entièrement derrière ces
manifestations
de la des foules en France entre les
blagues blocs qui sont les gilets jaunes
potentiellement qui ne sont pas dirigés
par un syndicat donc c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué pour la police juré les
manifestations que ça a été autrefois
quand c'était une immense appelé par les
syndicats dont plus par des cas pour les
syndicats donc on savait qui était
responsable mais c'est encadrement
réussi ça a été le cas pendant les 8
premières années de de exactement ont
réussi à convenir alors ça c'est un
premier point deuxième point c'est qu'il
faut pas généraliser non plus que toute
la police est violente la police de la
manière dont on a entendu c'est une
infime minorité mais malheureusement
c'est comme une infime minorité et
enregistrée ou photographié sa noircit
l'image de la police en général donc il
faut faire très attention par faire une
généralisation de la situation en France
ceci dit il y a un vrai problème donc
les actions il y a un vrai problème de
formation il y a un vrai problème de
manque de moyens et je pense que tous
ces facteurs mélangés ensemble faire en
sorte que on voit de plus en plus de
dérapages aujourd'hui comme avec pas vu
on voyait pas autrefois et ça c'est
quelque chose qui malheureusement pour
l'image de la France quand on voit ça de
la Grande-Bretagne et très négatif pour
les autres pays aussi j'ai une question
parce que le phénomène Black Bloc c'est
un phénomène européen il y en a eu en
Suisse Zurich il y en a aussi au
Royaume-Uni
comment les autres pays s'y prennent
est-ce que partout les Black Blocs et
suivez sont aussi violents ou est-ce que
c'est spécifiquement en France et
comment la police de vos pays respectifs
les interpellent ou les ou les empêche
d'agir que j'ai c'était en l'occurrence
si vous vous souvenez le G7 déviant qui
avait eu lieu je me souviens plus
l'année je crois que c'était 2003 ou
2004 de mémoire il y avait eu énormément
de casse à Genève à l'initiative de
bandes dans lesquelles c'était glissé
les Black Blocs donc c'était des
militants alternatifs à l'intérieur des
Black Bloc la police suisse avait choisi
de ne pas intervenir elle avait laissé
casser mais enfin elle avait limité la
casse mais elle avait choisi de ne pas
aller au contact et ça lui a été
reproché il y avait énormément de
vitrines cassées ensuite mais le choix
délibéré avait été fait de ne pas
affronter directement alors je vais on
va on va reprendre certains des
arguments qu'on a qu'on a donné et je
voulais vous entendre en premier sur la
visite de Charles III forcément mais
vous je vous ai pas donné la parole
là-dessus parce que en terme de d'image
évidemment et de et d'effet peut-être à
long terme dans l'image de la France
dans les opinions publiques européennes
ça me semble important vous posiez la
question de on se renvoie un peu la
patate chaude entre les Anglais et les
et les Britanniques bah écoutez ce que
ce que disait le président français
Emmanuel Macron sur sa prise de décision
en tout cas c'est comme ça qu'il le
disent ce matin de l'appeler et de lui
dire quel était la situation à partir du
moment où il y avait cette journée qui
avait été décidé le bon sens et l'amitié
nous conduisent à proposer un report ce
qui était détestable
pour le peuple britannique comme pour
nous-mêmes c'est au contraire
que nous essayons de maintenir comme si
de rien n'était avec des incidents à la
clé donc il faut organiser ça quand le
calme sera revenu et donc nous avons
proposé que au début de l'été en
fonction de nos agendas respectifs nous
puissions ensemble
quel est une nouvelle visite d'État
voilà donc j'ai pris l'initiative
d'appeler le le roi Charles III Anna
Navarro Pedro c'est un de faiblesse ou
de sagesse un peu des deux non mais
évidemment que c'est la faiblesse n'est
pas pouvoir de ne pas avoir l'attitude
qu'il faut dans ce pays pour amener le
calme social parce que le compromis et
la raidissement de l'État on a
l'impression qu'il vit dans le métabère
et non pas dans la réalité ce
gouvernement ce président mais
évidemment ça sept faiblesse là mais
c'est la sagesse même d'avoir annulé
c'était pas possible de venir c'était
une occasion trop belle pour protester
devant les caméras du monde entier
rendez compte et pourtant c'était un
beau cadeau avec saverly que le roi
Charles faisait à la France en
choisissant Paris comme première comme
première étape de visite de visite
d'État des étofficiers c'était un beau
cadeau alors bien évidemment je parle
sous le contrôle de Philippe d'abord
parce qu'il y a une dimension
personnelle on ne peut pas dissocier
Charles III du drame de Lady Diana de ce
qui s'était passé
sous le pont de l'Alma à Paris en 1997
donc il y avait une forme de rédemption
publique et Paris redevenait finalement
une ville qui retrouverait grâce aux
yeux du souverain britannique mais il y
avait aussi une dimension politique à
cette visite et la France en ce moment
et le Royaume-Uni ont besoin de se
rapprocher notamment sur des questions
de défense par rapport à la guerre en
Ukraine leur certes le roi est dans une
position tout à fait protocolaire mais
j'ai compris à lire la presque
britannique qu'il avait un certain
nombre de consignes de la part du
Premier ministre il avait reçu des
consignes du gouvernement et donc cette
partie politique qu'il faut pas quand
même l'ignorer la minorer parce que la
réalité on l'a pas encore dit c'est que
Charles III va se rendre en Allemagne
pour sa première visite d'État et donc
c'est un peu les Allemands qui vont
récolter les fruits de la contestation
et de la colère française Matthieu ce
qui est intéressant si on prend un peu
plus de recul pas seulement là sur cette
visite annulée pendant que les Français
contestaient compter cette réforme de
rentrée le président a passé beaucoup de
temps quand même sur la scène
internationale pour accueillir
aujourd'hui il y a pas de problème pour
partir et si on était un peu mauvaise
langue on dirait presque c'est devenu
pour lui une habitude à une Macron de
prendre la tangente quand ça chauffe à
la maison hop un petit sommet hop un
petit voyage bon alors reconnaissons
reconnaissons le d'emblée pardon la
politique étrangère de la France c'est
un domaine réservé du président de la
République et donc bien compréhensible à
ce titre de le voir courir le monde et
disons-le aussi tout net la situation
géopolitique actuelle avec la guerre en
Ukraine notamment la guerre commerciale
queive la Chine aux États-Unis la crise
migratoire ou encore la crise climatique
tout ça nécessite évidemment que le
président ne reste pas claque muret dans
son palais de l'Élysée mais quand même
quand on y pense l'accumulation de
sommets et d'engagement internationaux
ces derniers mois lui a permis de se
tenir à l'écart des soubresaut de la
réforme des retraites de laisser sa
première ministre en première ligne et
ce n'est pas près de s'arrêter parce
qu'après l'Afrique et des rencontres
européennes en mars se voilà qui
s'apprêtent à repartir dès le 5 avril
pour la Chine est-ce que c'est un bon
calcul bah oui et non les voyages à
l'étranger ça qui m'a permis d'esquiver
le feu roulant des questions des
journalistes vous savez c'est une sac
concentrègle en France qui veut qu'on
n'interroge pas le chef de l'État sur
des questions de politique à l'intérieur
de politique intérieure quand il est à
l'étranger et puis ça lui a permis aussi
de bouger de se déplacer sans prendre le
risque de déplacement au contact des
Français qui aurait été peut-être plus
problématique ou plus risqué mais lui
qui croyait prendre de la hauteur a
aussi pris une forme de distance et
alors que le pays traverse une crise
profonde sociale économique politique et
même pourquoi pas institutionnel cette
présence en pointillés nette pas alors
on est dans la symbolique je le
reconnais mais les symboles ça compte en
politique et puis surtout ça ne trompe
personne en fait parce que même loin des
yeux des Français c'est quand même lui
qui continue de tout décider et de se
mêler de tout je rappelle cette anecdote
du monde selon les le monde les services
de l'Elysée c'était assuré que l'avion
présidentiel en marge d'un déplacement
en Allemagne à le mi-février était bien
équipé d'un téléphone permettant
Emmanuel Macron d'autoriser Elisabeth
borne à recourir au 49-3
comme quoi même dans les airs on n'est
jamais trop prudent alors on va parler
des soutiens et puis peut-être du poids
d'Emmanuel Macron et donc de la France
aujourd'hui sur la scène européenne et
internationale tiens un soutien d'abord
celui de l'ancien Premier ministre
italien Mateo Renzi dans ce tweet qu'il
a lui-même rédigé en français il dit il
y a un leader en Europe qui ne regarde
pas au sondage mais au choix d'avenir
pour son pays et pour les nouvelles
générations je suis fier de notre amitié
bravo Monsieur le le Président
je voudrais vous entendre sur la
relation entre Emmanuel Macron et le
nouveau Premier ministre mais
britannique Christiana qui n'est venu en
France c'était le 10 mars dernier on a
affiché une bonne entente et c'est vrai
que ça contrastait on va dire avec ses
prédécesseurs est-ce que c'est pour
autant un allié potentiel d'Emmanuel
Macron sur la scène internationale je
pense que vu la la chute
de confiance entre les deux pays sont
tous avec Boris Johnson mais en gros
plus avec les strass qui était premier
ministre pendant 5 semaines qui refusait
même en public d'aider que Emmanuel
Macron a été alliés maintenant le plus
important est pour Emmanuel Macron et
pour Richie sunac c'est trop les
nappages et nous avons en face de nous
un premier ministre britannique qui est
un peu l'Emmanuel Macron de l'Angleterre
de la Grande-Bretagne parce qu'ils
viennent du même environnement c'est des
banquiers c'est des jeunes hommes c'est
des gens dynamiques et donc ils se
retrouvent et je pense que oui shissouna
on est en train de était le meilleur
choix dans la situation actuelle qui
trouvait la Grande-Bretagne après la fin
de la chute de l'estros l'année dernière
et donc il est important de tourner la
page non pas seulement pour tous les
années de Dongola de taux du brexit sur
les pêcheurs en France ou le protocole
irlandais sur la question des migrants
qui viennent de Calais jusqu'à Douvres
donc il y a plein de dossiers où il y
avait vraiment pas de discussion et là
je pense que dans les deux côtés il est
important de tourner la page et de
vraiment retrouver une nouvelle harmonie
de travail et donc la visite du
workshion c'était un peu la la le summum
dans cette
euh nouvelle vie franco-britannique qui
a malheureusement échoué pour le moment
mais je pense que du côté britannique et
du côté français quand j'entends
Emmanuel Macron qui dit voilà bon le
remettre au mois de juillet je pense que
vraiment les deux pays ils ont envie de
construire une nouvelle ère à partir de
maintenant cette visite royale elle aura
lieu euh
rapidement enfin ça va je pense qu'on va
sortir de cette crise mais vous savez
organiser une visite d'État ça se fait
pas en 5 minutes c'est ça donc c'est
quelque chose qui nécessite une un
planning à longue haleine mais puisque
tout a été mis sur place pour que ça
commence hier jusqu'à mercredi cette
semaine bon ils vont prendre les mêmes
plans et les mettre un peu plus tard non
peut-être que la moitié du travail est
déjà fait mais c'est vrai que c'est un
peu bouleversé l'emploi du temps du roi
parce qu'il a pas que ça à faire
malheureusement pour venir juste en
France il a d'autres d'autres visites à
faire mais je pense que c'est important
pour la Grande-Bretagne que cette visite
ait lieu le plus rapidement possible
c'est important parce qu'il avait un
discours qui était ici au Sénat on avait
un dispositif merveilleux à vous
proposer donc en effet on espère pouvoir
le ressortir qui dorment pas trop
longtemps dans les tiroirs je redeviens
sérieux à un avopédro sur le le poids
d'un Emmanuel Macron peut-être aussi
comment son image a évolué chez ses
homologues européens depuis depuis qu'il
est arrivé au pouvoir
je peux parler de Lisbonne mais
peut-être d'autres capitales aussi il a
émerveillé au départ si jeune nouveau
président français qui avait réussi à
être élu venant sans aucun parti
politique et sans les vieux parcours
traditionnels des Français des
politiciens français et qui en plus
admirateur et défendeur de l'Europe
d'une Europe forte de la défense
européenne etc donc vraiment il était
admiré pour cela ensuite commencer de
ton passe commencer à parler avec bon un
peu tout le monde à Lisbonne etc
ailleurs et on vous dit oui il fait
beaucoup d'annonces très fortes et
discours merveilleux mais ensuite on
veut faire quelque chose derrière on
coulisse en contact en téléphone on
lance les bases on propose de faire
quelque chose ensemble
on travaille sur ce qui a été proposé et
ça n'a pas été d'après mes
interlocuteurs ça n'a pas vraiment été
fait donc il y a eu beaucoup d'annonces
d'effets d'annonces et peu de travail
derrière fait donc un peu vide pour
beaucoup de monde et ensuite c'est son
côté merveilleux qui était sa force au
départ de vouloir avancer avec l'Europe
avec la défense avec une Europe plus
forte plus indépendante etc mais qui on
a vu aussi qui a un caractère qui est un
caractère une bon sa nature sa
personnalité mais qui a une personnalité
qui n'aime pas la contradiction
qui aime gagner à tout prix dans le
débat et du pouvoir dans ton parler tout
à l'heure que on ne pourrait le
souhaiter en Europe et donc voilà son
image c'est un tout petit peu perdu son
lustre Richard Berli est-ce que un chef
d'État qui est fragilisé sur son sol
général plutôt économique continue de
bien-aimer et comme Mathéo Renzi Mateo
Renzi appartient un peu à ce monde-là on
félicite Macron de tenir bon parce que
pension reform la réforme des retraites
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel et puis
il y a tous les autres tous ceux qui ne
sont pas dans ce monde-là l'Afrique
l'Amérique latine un certain nombre de
pays européens qui s'inquiètent aussi
pour leur modèle social là c'est plus
compliqué paradoxalement peut-être que
ceux qui aujourd'hui serre la main avec
le plus d'enthousiasme Emmanuel Macron
c'est les régimes illibéraux européens
les polonais ou les Hongrois Orban et il
n'y a pas longtemps à Paris parce que
finalement il maintenant et Madame
Macron ne peut plus leur faire beaucoup
de reproches c'est plus difficile pour
lui et et eux ils incarnent une figure
autoritaire qu'ils assument et Emmanuel
Macron est un peu dans cette posture
aussi alors on a voulu aussi se poser la
question de ce mouvement finalement de
de grève est-ce qu'il y a aussi et
j'appelle Steve Jourdain à nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau d'autres grèves
en ce moment dans d'autres pays d'Europe
Steve bienvenue le rideau s'ouvre et
l'entrée remarquable parce qu'il y a pas
mal de mouvements de grève ailleurs en
Europe direction la première économie
d'Europe l'Allemagne ou l'inflation
interne atteint les
8,7%, ce lundi une mobilisation massive
à paralyser le secteur des transports
grève dans les trains les bus les
tramways les aéroports les sociétés
d'autoroute le mot d'ordre est simple et
syndicat de salariés demandent de
meilleurs de meilleurs salaires pour
compenser l'inflation écoutez
pour se chauffer sont extrêmement élevés
le prix de l'essence est au plus haut
chaque achat de produits est un
casse-tête
augmente pour qu'on puisse continuer à
vivre une grève qui s'inscrit dans un
contexte de mobilisation dans plusieurs
autres secteurs au mois de janvier et de
février les employés de la poste et les
salariés de l'industrie se sont aussi
mis en grève toujours pour demander des
hausses de salaire tu m'avais on
continue notre tour d'Europe d'autres
pays qui connaissent des tensions grève
également au Royaume-Uni et au Portugal
de côté de la Manche et nos amis
britanniques on assiste plus importants
cycle de grève depuis les années 80 il y
a deux semaines le pays a même connu la
plus importante journée d'action depuis
plusieurs années transport à l'arrêt
enseignant en grève secteur de la santé
paralysé là-bas l'inflation dépasse les
10% les prix de l'alimentaire et de
l'énergie flambe les salariés demandent
donc des augmentations la semaine
dernière des négociations ont été
entamées avec les syndicats les choses
pourraient se débloquer dans les
prochains jours même revendications
salariale au Portugal ou l'inflation a
atteint ces derniers mois des niveaux
jamais vu depuis 30 ans plus 7,8% sur
l'ensemble de l'année 2022 il y a dix
jours les services publics se sont mis
en grève et les Portugais sont descendus
dans la rue en pensant un peu à nous
écouter
nous voyons chaque jour à la télévision
les manifestants en France qui luttent
pour que le
gouverneur est à 64 ans
au Portugal notre retraite est à 66 ans
et 7 mois
j'ai 63 ans et je dois m'occuper de
patients plus jeunes que moi dont
certains pèsent plus de 100 kg je vais
devoir continuer à travailler comme ça
encore plusieurs années pour un salaire
de misère et sans espoir d'être
revalorisé ce n'est pas normal c'est
pour ça que je suis dans la rue
en réaction assez mobilisation le
gouvernement socialiste a annoncé à de
nouvelles mesures d'aide au ménage
j'aurais aussi pu vous parler Thomas de
la mobilisation des contrôleurs aériens
qui a lieu tous les lundis en Espagne
mais vous avez compris l'idée générale
il y a aujourd'hui en Europe beaucoup de
tension sociale dans un contexte de
forte inflation et de remonter des taux
d'intérêts merci Steve Jourdain pour
toutes ces explications
modièse un hashtag en ce moment en
Angleterre enfin dans les pays
britanniques
Philippe sol c'est BIM of French je sais
pas si vous l'avez vu alors c'est de
l'humour où ça où ça représente quand
même un petit mouvement je pense que
soyez plus français c'est un peu les
deux puisque on regarde beaucoup ce qui
se passe en France moi j'ai souvent des
appels qui me disent mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe à Paris c'est la révolution
fais attention à vous parce qu'on voit
que les plus mauvaise image
le pays est enflamme mais il est vrai
que bon viendront de son situation est
quand même pas très bonne un compagne il
y a eu beaucoup de manifestations de
grève sur tous les infirmières pour une
augmentation de prix ils ont perdu on
estime entre 15 et 20% de leur
capacité de de d'achat donc pouvoir
d'achat donc il y a il y a beaucoup de
respect parce que le parti conservatoire
qui est au pouvoir depuis 13 ans a coupé
dans toutes les dépenses partout dans
les services publics donc les gens
disent maintenant on peut plus vivre
avec les moyens du beau vu la
augmentation d'inflation veut
augmentation des prix partout en jointe
tous les deux bouts à la fin du mois un
peu comme en France d'ailleurs et donc
on fait grève mais à l'OCCA en France on
fait on fait des manifestations
comme on voit ici on a moins tendance à
faire les manifestations qui deviennent
violents en Grande-Bretagne c'est une
différence on fait grève mais on se
manifeste moins qu'on se manifeste en
France
le gouvernement a écouté augmenter les
salaires mais il faut savoir aussi que
20 % des Britanniques vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté ce qui est quand même
gigantesque plus qu'en France et que
l'âge de la retraite c'est déjà 66 ans
et pour les femmes et pour les hommes et
on pense les discussions que ça va
augmenter à 68 ans d'ici une dizaine
d'années même peut-être plus donc
ça un moment où la la l'espérance de vie
en Grande-Bretagne est en train de
baisser donc donc la situation est
comparable à celle en France donc quand
on parle de 64 ans ici les gens disent
mais on comprend pas nous les gens on
est à 65 66 ans comme ça se fait qu'il
se manifeste pour juste 64 ans nous on
aimerait bien y retourner on est même
pas là on est même au-delà des 64 ans
Richard Berl peut-être une forme de
d'arrogance française mais on a toujours
l'impression que tout le monde nous
regarde mais en l'occurrence que comment
comment vous vous le percevez c'est
assez est-ce que ce mouvement
qui dure donc forcément ça ça peut
intéresser plus de de média avec à la
fois le fait que ça dure depuis
longtemps et puis le crescendo
malheureusement dans dans la violence
est-ce que ça peut servir de leçon
est-ce que comment c'est observé d'après
vous dans les autres pays européens et
notamment Suisse mais pas en Suisse
alors d'abord on aurait pu rajouter la
Suisse au pays où il y a des
manifestations ça va peut-être vous
étonner mais il y a eu des
manifestations notamment de la part des
fonctionnaires pour des revalorisations
salariales et dans un certain nombre de
branches industrielles or pourtant la
Suisse est un pays où les salaires sont
plus élevés que la moyenne européenne
donc ça prouve bien que le mal est
profond oui la France est regardée et
oui cette capacité de révolte de colère
sociale de la France je dirais pas
qu'elle est admirée parce qu'on en
connaît les conséquences notamment sur
le plan d'ambiance mais elle est
respectée par contre je reviens au début
de ce que je disais qu'on ne comprend
pas c'est pourquoi cette colère
finalement n'est pas entendu par le
gouvernement et pourquoi le gouvernement
et la population ne parviennent pas à
trouver une solution notamment les
partenaires sociaux font la grande
interrogation vue de Suisse elle est pas
tant sur la colère des Français la
colère des Français on la comprend c'est
le système français qu'on ne comprend
pas et puis aussi enfin imaginez que au
Portugal il est en plus de ce climat de
revendications sur le pouvoir d'achat
une réforme des retraites enfin vous
voyez ce que je veux dire faire cette
est-ce que c'est pas je sais pas comment
le dire ça un signe de de perte de
contact avec le pays réel de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron d'avoir fait une telle
réforme en ce moment c'était la c'était
au départ la critique principale on ne
comprend pas qu'il pousse cette réforme
telle qu'elle est en ce moment même
dans un pays qui peut être n'est pas
aussi affecté par l'inflation et par les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat que les
autres mais qui on est très affecté déjà
donc on ne comprend pas ça mais on suit
effectivement vous avez vu cette
manifestante portugais qui disait on
regarde les Français on les comprend et
pareil la même compréhension je le
disais d'ailleurs au départ c'est
incompréhension qui n'est aucun
compromis aucun dialogue aucun contact
entre le mouvement social olé
représentant du mouvement social et
l'exécutif je voudrais qu'on voit
quelques images de ces nous font pas
plaisir à voir mais bon de ces poubelles
amassées dans Paris la situation elle
s'améliore tout doucement on va dire on
est autour de 7000 tonnes encore de
déchets non ramassés pour terminer il
nous reste assez peu de temps dans ce
débat mais j'aurais quand même vous
entendre là-dessus et peut-être vous
filter le pour commencer parce que je
voudrais qu'on parle des Jeux olympiques
de Paris
non vous voulez pas c'est une Londres il
y a eu l'ombre il y a eu Londres c'était
2012 est-ce qu'il y a eu des mouvements
sociaux avant lourdes parce que ça peut
être aussi l'occasion de manifester pour
revendiquer et obtenir quelque chose
vous voyez ce que je pense que la grande
crainte de tout gouvernement c'est quand
il y a un événement planétaire comme
montagne dans moins d'un mois que que
cet événement soit pris en otage par les
manifestants par les demandes
d'augmentation de salaire pour obtenir
ce qu'ils veulent on n'est pas on n'est
pas à l'abri de ça en France il est vrai
pour les Jeux Olympiques vus ce qui se
passe en ce moment mais je pense que le
mouvement actuel sur l'augmentation de
l'âge pour partir à la retraite ça sert
à régler bien avant
autre chose qui va se manifester d'ici
là et on répond à votre question en 2012
on a pas eu vraiment de manifestations
mais il est vrai que dans certains
secteurs ils ont dit voilà nous on
travaille on va pas travailler pour
pardonnez-moi le terme des clopinettes
pour construire les stades etc et mettre
tout ça en route donc il faut que ce
soit des salaires qui soient dignes du
travail qu'on demande de faire ça a été
entendu pour le par le gouvernement
parce que je pense que ils ont compris
qu'il y a rien de pire sur une image
pour les Jeux Olympiques que d'avoir un
pays en grève ou que les Jeux Olympiques
les bâtiments soient pas prêts à ton pot
pour le début des jeux et ça c'est tout
le défi quand la France doit prendre en
compte le gouvernement efface cela il y
a très peu de temps donc ils ont intérêt
ce problème des retraites parce que il
est vrai que bon la visite du Rochat a
été malheureusement pas autorisé parce
que on avait peur de quelque chose mais
les Jeux Olympiques c'est beaucoup plus
grand évidemment il y a beaucoup plus de
danger on est bien d'accord alors il y a
une quand même un savoir-faire français
en matière d'organisation de grands
événements sportifs dans le passé on a
su on a su faire donc ça pourrait
peut-être une grosse à la finale de la
Ligue des Champions
j'en ai déjà parlé Richard c'est pas
bien de se moquer donc je sais bien que
cet événement là c'est mal passé mais
auparavant il y avait un vrai
savoir-faire mais est-ce que c'est pas
ça tiens on va terminer là-dessus le
plus grand défi de ce second quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron réussir à apaiser le
pays avant avant un événement planétaire
comme les Jeux Olympiques sûrement moi
ce qui me frappe c'est outre les défis
défis sur le plan de je crois la
sécurité des transports c'est les deux
choses qui remontent le plus moi surtout
ce que je vois c'est le défi pour
l'image de Paris par moi mais Paris les
Jeux Olympiques ça devrait faire vibrer
le monde entier c'est Paris c'est les JO
c'est aussi le centenaire des Jeux
olympiques de 1924 c'est toute une
symbolique et pour l'instant avoué que
la fièvre olympique à Paris on ne la
voit pas du tout ne serait-ce qu'au
niveau de la du marketing de la
commercialisation c'est dans 18 mois
c'est quand même c'est quand même demain
18 mois et moi c'est ça que je trouve
plus triste c'est qu'Emmanuel Macron
j'espère que ils vont ressusciter cette
fièvre de Paris parce que pour la ville
c'est un tremplin extraordinaire et il
faut pas le rater aujourd'hui on a
presque l'impression pardon que Paris
aujourd'hui n'a pas envie des JO
j'espère que on vous démentira dans les
prochaines semaines et dans les
prochains mois
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat et à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat
le prochain invité politique sur notre
antenne dans la matinale Oriane Mancini
reçoit Sylvain Maillard député
renaissance de Paris merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité on a fait de très
belles audiences en février ça fait
toujours plaisir et donc je le dis parce
que si je le dis pas personne le dit
allez bonne soirée salut